the movie begins with a man named Paul
Conroy regaining Consciousness inside a
dark and small enclosure with his hands
and mouth tied there is a lighter nearby
and when he ignites it he shockingly
discovers that he is trapped inside a
coffin after a lot of struggle Paul
removes the cloth covering his mouth and
starts screaming for help but he soon
realizes that no one can hear him after
that he attempts to open the coffin to
get out but the task is increasingly
difficult as his hands are still bound
this is going to unlock a new kind of
nightmare for me Paul then notices a
nail and uses it to somehow free his
hands he breathes a sigh of relief and
once again summons all of his strength
to try to open the coffin but without
success he begins to lose all hope and
starts screaming loudly suddenly Paul
hears the sound of something vibrating
upon inspecting he discovers a phone
much to his relief he uses the phone to
call the emergency helpline and
fortunately it goes through when an
operator answers the call Paul
introduces himself as an American
citizen who is working in Iraq as a
truck driver you then gets straight to
the point revealing that he is buried in
a coffin with no clue about his current
location however to his dismay the
operator mentions that she is based in
Ohio and can't do much to help him Paul
even calls his wife several times but
she doesn't answer probably because she
is out somewhere so he drops her a
message saying that he is stuck in Iraq
and asks her to inform the National
Guard after this Paul calls the Chicago
FBI an agent gets on the line and Paul
immediately starts explaining his ordeal
he reveals that he was working as a
truck driver in Iraq and one day when he
was on his way to deliver kitchen
supplies to a community center some
children started throwing stones at him
then some people came from behind and
started shooting at them resulting in
the deaths of several of his companions
the last thing Paul remembers is being
struck in the head with a stone and
collapsing when he gained Consciousness
he found himself inside the coffin as
Paul continues to explain the signal is
abruptly lost and the call gets
disconnected Paul frantically points the
mobile phone to every corner that he can
reach and when the signal finally
appears he calls the same number however
this time the call is connected to
another agent she asks him for the
security code to their previous
conversation but sadly Paul didn't note
it down so the call goes to voicemail
and eventually ends I've been there it
finally begins to Dawn on Paul that he
may not make it out alive however he
suddenly remembers that when he was on
the call with the FBI he received a
missed call on his phone he calls back
the number and on the other side a man
picks up and asks if he is an American
Soldier Paul says I am not an American
Soldier I am just an ordinary truck
driver who works for a company in Iraq
however the man doesn't believe him and
says if you are an American then you are
also a soldier the man then tells Paul
that if he wants to get out of this
predicament he must give him five
million dollars and he has until nine
o'clock pm to do so if he doesn't
provide the money the man will bury him
alive turns out this is the same man who
has caused all this mess in response
Paul nervously tells him that he doesn't
have that much money as he is just an
ordinary truck driver if he had that
kind of money he wouldn't have come to
work in Iraq however the man suggests
that Paul should contact the American
Embassy and discuss the matter with them
he is sure that they will pay 5 Milli to
set an American citizen free saying this
the man hangs up the call Paul is pretty
sure that the American Embassy would
never give such a large amount of money
for a driver however he still calls the
state government after obtaining the
number from his sister-in-law as Paul
provides them with all the information
about his situation the woman on the
line informs him that she already knows
about him it turns out when he sent the
voice message earlier it reached them
instantly Paul then explains that the
kidnapper has asked for a ransom of 5
million dollars and if he doesn't
receive the money they will leave him to
die unfortunately the woman says that
they cannot provide five million dollars
because it goes against their policy as
they don't negotiate with any terrorists
this frustrates Paul and he tells her
that it's easy for her to make a
decision while sitting in a room but
he's the one he's about to die within a
few hours just tell them you're Ryan
Reynolds dude that'll that'll get it
done he asks her what will happen to his
family after his death hearing this the
woman finally pities him and gives him
the number of a man named Dan who is the
commander of the hostage group in Iraq
she says that he will definitely assist
in this matter hopeful Paul quickly
calls Dan and the latter reveals that he
already knows about his predicaments he
advises Paul not to panic and assures
him that he will be safe outside before
nine o'clock Dan also advises Paul to
mute his phone to save battery and take
longer breaths to save oxygen inside the
coffin just after Paul hangs up the call
the kidnapper calls him again Paul
informs him that the American government
has refused to pay the money because he
is just an ordinary truck driver
surprisingly the kidnapper believes him
and agrees to bring down the ransom to
one million dollars not much of a Hagler
this guy he also orders Paul to record a
video of him asking the American
government for ransom the kidnapper then
explains that a bag is present inside
the coffin and it contains a small
script Paul will have to read it out to
make the video up until this point
antagonist was unaware that there are
other contents inside the coffin but
when he looks towards his feet he finds
the bag and becomes excited inside he
finds a light a script a knife and a
bottle of alcohol perfect Let's Get
Crunk Paul then decides to call his wife
but again fails to reach her just then
he notices that he is running out of
battery he doesn't understand what to do
so he calls Dan and informs him that the
kidnapper has ordered him to make a
video Dan doesn't give the approval but
promises that they are doing their best
and will get him out soon to assure Paul
he talks about a 23 year old student who
they rescued two weeks ago however Paul
is still very nervous so he calls his
mommy she answers it immediately but
fails to recognize her own son as she is
suffering from a mental condition
nevertheless Paul tells her that this
might be the last time he can talk to
her and that he loves her very much just
then Paul gets a photo message of her
friend Pamela from the kidnapper she
used to work with him in Iraq and it's
revealed that the kidnappers have also
captured her in the photo a man is
pointing a gun at her seeing this Paul
gets scared and immediately calls the
kidnapper the latter warns him that if
he doesn't send the video he will kill
his friend Paul promises to do what he
says and pleads with the kidnapper to
not harm Pamela he says that she has two
children however the kidnapper responds
that he had five children and the
American soldiers killed two of them
after he hangs up the call Paul quickly
records the video in which he states
that he is an American citizen who's
been kidnapped in Iraq he now needs one
million dollars by 9 pm in exchange for
his life after Paul sends the video to
the kidnapper he notices a horrifying
sight a venomous snake has snuck inside
the coffin through a hole initially he
pan
screams out loud but once he calms down
he comes up with an idea he uses the
alcohol he found in the bag to set a
fire and scare the snake away saving his
life right after Paul receives a video
message on his phone in it his friend
Pamela says that despite being an
American citizen the American government
didn't help her or fulfill the
kidnapper's demands at the end of the
video a person shoots her in the head
much to Paul's horror he panics and
vomits all over the coffin he begins to
believe that he is surely going to die
Paul then receives a call from Dan
informing him that he shouldn't have
recorded the video because it was a move
by the kidnappers to put pressure on the
U.S government currently the video has
amassed 47 000 views on YouTube as the
two continue talking Paul hears the
sound of prayers coming from a mosque in
the distance he informs Dan about this
and the latter tells him not to worry
claiming that he is really close to
rescuing him suddenly there is a huge
explosion causing the upper part of the
coffin to crack this allows sand to seep
inside in huge mouths panicking Paul
scrambles to use his clothes to block
the holes he then receives a call from
Dan who tells him that his men carried
out the attack and the kidnapper might
have died in the explosion however the
sand continues to fill the coffin
causing Paul's hope to dwindle further
therefore he decides to record a final
video for his wife and son becoming
highly emotional just then the kidnapper
who had survived the attack calls him
again he reminds Paul that his time is
running out and if he wants to stay
alive he should quickly Fork over that
one mill however Paul refuses stating
that the government won't provide any
money in response the kidnapper
instructs him to cut his own finger and
create a video to put more pressure on
the government when Paul declines the
kidnapper threatens to kill his wife and
son he even goes as far as revealing
their home address this scares Paul and
he decides to cut his finger and make a
video for the sake of his family
suddenly he Witnesses a ray of light
coming from above and he is about to be
rescued however he soon realizes that he
has hallucinating Paul is still trapped
inside the coffin with nowhere to go
just then he receives a call from Dan
who mentions that they have found him
and will soon get him out in the
meantime Paul finally gets a call from
his wife while crying hysterically she
inquires about his well-being he assures
her that he is fine and is about to be
rescued promising that he will soon
return home all this while sand
continues to pour into the coffin
threatening to bury Paul alive before he
can be rescued worried he calls Dan and
requests that he be saved as soon as
possible Dan assures him that they are
almost there however the moment he opens
the coffin he finds another man inside
when Paul hears this all of his hopes
are shattered and he finally accepts his
fate Dan who is still on the call
profusely apologizes that he couldn't
save him the movie ends as Sin
completely fills the coffin and the
lights go out
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching